Todd and Julie Chrisley get their
sentences following the couple's tax
evasion and fraud convictions what we
will not do is we will not break because
God didn't bring us this far to drop us
off Todd sentenced to 12 years in prison
his wife Julie nine years in prison and
both were given 16 months probation we
put our faith in God we definitely don't
but our faith and the system I've never
seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith last week E.T
spoke exclusively with Todd and Julie's
daughter Savannah as the family prepared
for their sentencing to me it's just so
admirable and that's kind of just my
focus is just watching them and then
still learning and growing from them
like this and just kind of staying
strong through it all and knowing that
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith back in June a prosecutor
said the reality stars engaged in
extensive bank fraud and hid their
wealth all while flaunting their super
lavish Lifestyle on TV we signed up for
a show that has entertained millions and
millions and millions of people but what
we didn't sign up for is to be live on
at the same time though there have been
reports that you having said just fix it
fix these documents fortify these
documents that's not true well this is
quite the legal mess yes listen we're
blessed because God has given us the
ability to you know I feel bad for
people in this country who don't have
the resources
to
to prove their innocence after a
three-week trial they were convicted on
all accounts for both Todd and Julie
that included conspiracy to commit bank
fraud bank fraud conspiracy to defraud
the United States and tax fraud and
Julie received an additional conviction
for wire fraud what they basically did
is they provided fraudulent documents to
financial institutions and the way that
the federal government was able to prove
this case was not just based on those
actual documents but it was also based
on emails text messages between the
Chrisleys along with one of the
Cooperators who came forward to tell the
government what the Chrisleys had done